i wanted to take this opportunity to say
thank you to our daily wire subscribers
thank you for supporting uh my film what
is a woman this is one of the most
important projects that daily wire has
ever embarked on and you our subscribers
made it a massive success in fact the
daily wire had its biggest streaming
week ever and i'm so incredibly humbled
by your outpouring of support for the
film truth is we can't make
documentaries like what is a woman
without subscribers like you and it's
important to point this out because too
often
as conservatives you know we complain
about paying for another subscription
service while we're more than willing to
give our money to other streaming
services that are actively merchandising
the destruction of our values and our
culture
we're talking about subscription
services who intentionally make shows
with the expressed purpose of
indoctrinating children with radical
gender ideology and so many other things
too i won't name names but you know you
know who they are
you can't trust these media giants
anymore but you can trust us
and while we may not have easy access to
hollywood's billions or endless ad
dollars pouring in from woke corporate
america
we have something more powerful which is
you our loyal supporters when you become
a subscriber you help us change the
conversation and ultimately the culture
with documentaries like what is a woman
and there's much more on the way this
month really excited about the premiere
of daily wires original film uh tara on
the prairie next week starring gina
carano hollywood tried to cancel gina so
he gave her her own movie and that's
what we do right after that candace
owens will blow the lid off of blm's
deception in her new documentary the
greatest lie ever told george floyd and
the rise of blm
so again thank you and if you haven't
yet subscribed join the daily wire right
now and watch what is a woman the
documentary that's blowing up the
internet and now as a token of my
appreciation
let me give you something you've never
seen before
that was me smiling